[Music]
so it's very bright up here I can barely
see you I'm really excited to be here
today I hope you are too I hope
everyone's learning a lot today before I
get started I'd like to take just a
moment to thank the next event staff we
can't do things like this without them
so let's all give a real quick round of
applause for the folks that made this
possible for us thanks that's awesome so
the other thing I'd like to do before I
before I get started I'd like to remind
you to provide feedback for all the for
all the sessions that you've attended
today including this one and we use that
feedback to ensure that future topics
are relevant high quality and compelling
so please do take the time to let us
know how you how you feel about the
content real quick about myself I'm a my
name is Jeremy Johnson I'm a product
manager with Google cloud I specifically
work on networking my my primary focus
in product management is around IP
addressing and we were actually doing a
panel on IP addressing tomorrow so
please come at 9:00 a.m. when tomorrow
and listen to IP addressing talk as well
I think one of the things I've been at
Google for about a year and a half and
one of the things that's really awesome
about working at Google is working with
world-class engineers I mean I've worked
with some great engineers over my career
I've been doing this for about 25 years
and I've really honestly never worked
with such a great group of people and
it's my honor today to present some of
the work that they've done to create
what I consider probably the greatest
network on the planet and hopefully I
can do that justice so our goals today
are really simple we're gonna go over
our global network which if you've been
following the the operations track
you've probably heard a lot about over
the last couple of days you're gonna
hear more about it today we're also
going to talk about the Andromeda
architecture which is our
software-defined network that operates
our cloud it's not the only
software-defined network with it we run
but it's the one we're talking about
today
and then finally throughout this slides
I'm hoping to get across some of the
practical benefits of the of the
architecture and infrastructure that
we've that we've put together
so this slide probably looks familiar to
some folks and and I hope it I hope it
does but we think this is really
important this is this is a view of our
global network and it's important to
think about when you think about
Google's cloud it's important to think
about the global network the reason for
that is that everything we do centers
around this thing this this global
interconnected network that we've built
and we're pretty proud of it some
numbers for you we've got 20 cloud
regions I think if you were here last
year that number was significantly
smaller I think it was in the
single-digit digits last year so we've
we've been expanding really fast
yeah 125 pops the pops are where are
where we connect to the internet and and
also provide edges of those 125 pops 90
of them service CDN locations 72 of them
serve as dedicated interconnect
locations we've got 15 Google data
centers so not every region has its own
has its own data center that might be a
little bit confusing but trust me we've
also got 26 renewable energy project
locations hundreds of thousands of miles
of fiber-optic cable and 13 subsea Cable
investments so we've put a lot into this
infrastructure to make what we again
think is probably the best network on
the planet so the question I guess is
why does this really matter and to me it
comes down to two things it's less work
for y'all and it also provides more more
more options and what do I mean by less
work when we when we think about things
globally and we offer you global
constructs you're able to do things like
create one VPC globally without
replicating it across multiple regions
and then having to worry about
replicating configuration and
connectivity across all those regions
and replicating all of your all of your
policies across all of those regions for
us it's one global VPC and we've
things like the shared VPC and host
projects so that you can really leverage
that we'll talk more about that in a
minute
also we we've created a whole bunch of
services that work both at the global
level and at the regional level so for
example some of our global services are
things like the late
layer 7 global anycast bibs this
provides the ability to to do load
balancing at a global level without
having to play games with DNS etc we've
got many interconnect locations across
the globe we also have differentiated
network tiers we've got what we call a
premium tier and a standard tier
actually we've got a booth outside that
shows kind of really what's going on
there but the difference between the
network tiers is really simple the
premium tiers leverages the entire
global network so your traffic can enter
our network anywhere and it can exit
anywhere in the network the regional
services or the standard network tier
allows traffic to enter in in in a
region in a regional location or
someplace approximately close to a
region so the pops nearby a region and
also that now allows traffic to only
exit that those places and these are
choices that you might make based on
cost you might make them based on local
rules or compliance compliance purposes
so again this is really really
interesting and compelling from my
perspective because you've got more
choices I think with our network and our
cloud specifically when it comes to
networking than any other cloud so I'm
sure you've all seen that slide before
of the global network so I kind of
wanted to give you an idea of what
really goes into that and so what we've
got here is a picture of one of the
fibre ducts out or actually a fiber
trench and several dozen fired Fiber
ducts outside one of our data center
campuses and the thing that's
interesting about this is that each one
of those orange pipes has thousands of
strands of fiber just for that one
campus and also we've got hundreds of
thousands of model fiber backbone
one of the things that one of the things
that's interesting about this backbone
is there's so much redundancy built into
it that we can lose we can lose many
connections and still have and still
achieve global reach ability so again
this is also the infrastructure that
that powers Google so I think you're all
well aware of our commitment to to
reliability at Google and I think you
know it probably is obvious how much how
much of a problem it would be if we if
we lost connectivity so this is this is
a major part of our part of our story so
I'm gonna I'm gonna take the time
nowadays to talk about some Network
functions and the way we're going to
organize this so I'm going to talk about
these network functions at a somewhat
high level and then we're gonna dig dig
down deeper into them and talk about how
we actually make those things happen
so it all starts with this global VP see
the idea of a global VP see is that we
can have multiple clients running on the
same network using overlapping Network
namespaces we all use 10.0 for something
but they're all checked out they're all
sharing the same the same network
infrastructure right so this requires us
to build functional and performance
isolation for all for all of our clients
oops I should be using that I don't know
what side I'm on now I apologize so
network functions we talked a little bit
about the global load balancer I want to
talk about it a little bit more so with
a global network we're able to provide
at those pop locations we're able to
provide load balancers that present a
single global IP to all of your clients
across across the world so one VIP with
the same IP address serving the entire
globe in the way that we're able to do
that is we leverage a technology called
anycast which really means that we're
advertising the same IP addresses at all
of our locations that we fight and we've
I feed your VIP with that same IP
at each one of those locations what this
does is it attracts traffic from our
peers to the to the most geographically
proximate ingress location and then from
there we backhaul that to the to
whatever cloud back-end you have serving
it this enables you to do global load
balancing again without without
manipulating DNS or in fact taking
sometimes signals from DNS that are that
are potentially inaccurate so this
slides a bit of a bit of a mess so I'm
gonna try and walk you through it what
we have here this is an engineering
conversation right you aren't expecting
really beautiful slides were you so
anyway we're gonna start we're gonna
start from I guess your right side and
walk it towards me
so what we what we've got here is a
basic example of a VPN using our global
network and again this is about choice
and ease of use so let's say you've got
your on-prem network and you've got this
green VPN termination device at your end
you're going to traverse the internet
with your with your IPSec tunnel and
you're gonna land that at a VPN gateway
in a cloud region right so when it lands
in that cloud region you've got some
choices you can you can first of all
just use resources in that cloud region
and route back to that VPN termination
point through that tunnel or you can
export the routes using our cloud router
and also a toggle called route called
global routes to route all the
information that your project learns
from the VPN globally and that's just a
simple toggle so you can either isolate
your VPN endpoint locally or you can or
you can enable it globally likewise you
can advertise your routes from from
Google in that you learn from Google
back across that that VPN connection
including any routes that your VPC has
globally and you do that with a
mechanism called custom routes and this
is just a small example also I've got in
there
a layer for ILB the interesting thing
about that is that you can you can
literally use an internal load balancer
at the far end of a VPN connection to
load balanced internal traffic again
anywhere in the world and we're gonna
talk a little bit more about how that
works in a minute so the network load
balancer is it is interesting this is
more of a regional construct but the
interesting thing about the network load
balancer is it actually uses our edge
pops as well because this is for public
Internet traffic coming into into a
cloud region but it's it's not load
balanced at layer 7 so when we talk
about the global load balancer the layer
7 VIP that does termination so it
actually terminates an HTTP connection
it terminates an SSL connection or a
proxies TCP this is actually a layer 3
layer 4 load balancer that directs
traffic to two backends in a cloud
region a specific cloud region so if you
wanted to load balance across multiple
regions in this case you would actually
deploy load balancers in each region
that you wanted to load balance and so
in this in this situation we've got Maya
in California Bob in London and Shannon
Singapore and a couple of the
interesting things about this this load
balancing capability is that we do
preserve the the client IP address so
that we can do direct server return and
also it facilitates creating firewall
rules on the cloud backends and this is
kind of important again to make things
easy you have the same IP address on
your on your lb VIP as you do on your on
your back-end VIP and so it's just one
firewall rule at the regional level to
to manage security for those connections
another regional function this one's
more truly regional is the internal load
balancer we talked about it a little bit
in in the case of the the VPN but sort
of how it works is again it allows you
to create an internal VIP but in this
case it's completely programmed in a
distributed fashion across across our
Andromeda infrastructure there are no
middle boxes in this case in the other
cases
the global load balancer there's there's
a middle box that's doing termination in
the network load balancer case there's a
middle box that's actually that's
actually directing traffic at the edge
that's a something we call a maglev
internally in these internal load
balancers this is completely using the
distributed software-defined network
that we've built and it's actually
programming flows directly onto each
host and there are no middle boxes to
speak of again client IP addresses are
preserved it's easy to set it's easy to
control access with firewall rules and
we believe it offers higher performance
because of no choke points again no
middle boxes for these kinds of load
balancers so let's talk about a little
bit about how it works so again we
talked about that global that global V
PC so remember we've got a we've got to
do functional and performance isolation
and what that means is again every
project in cloud is using the same
infrastructure globally but you're all
operating on different or distinct
isolated networking or partner network
namespaces so we all have overlapping IP
addresses basically but you're also all
expecting us to provide performance
guarantees and so we also have to do
isolation at the performance level and
then finally we have to offer hyah bill
hyah veil ability to everyone so our
high availability targets and this is
interesting are we use a we use a
mnemonic called three four five so if
you deploy an application in a single
zone our target for availability is
three nines of availability if you if
you deploy across two zones and in the
same region or regionally as we would
call it then you would you would expect
four nines of availability and if you
deploy something globally across
multiple regions you should expect five
nines of availability on our network we
think number one that's unique but
number two that creates a whole bunch of
problems for us since if your
application availability needs to be
three four five that means that what
we're deploying is actually four five
six
so unified view of functions this is
where I go to the note cards so bear
with me for one second so where are we
okay so we wanted to spend some time on
the data plane and basically the idea
the message behind this slide is that
we've we've we've built the core network
functions into the VM host themselves
and that's a that's a consistent theme
across the Andromeda Network there's a
constant evolution of features that we
push out weekly and we support and we
can do this because we support live
migrations so that we can do host
maintenance in a non-disruptive fashion
and also we can do hitless upgrades of
our data plane and we'll talk a little
bit about how we can do that as well so
the architecture itself first of all is
replicated across regions its sharded
across regions and it's also sharded
across zones so what we've done is we
basically built a hierarchy of a control
plane that manages a data plane so the
first up at the top and you're not going
to see it in this slide is the cloud
cluster manager this performs a lot of
tasks including configuring storage it
also configures compute and networking
below that sits the fabric manager which
is a regional which is a regional level
control plane and that comprises a high
level API to configure virtual networks
and other functions and then you get
down to the ofe which is our open flow
layer which takes which takes our API
abstractions and then converts those
into into open flow program or open flow
configurations and programs those
constructs directly to the switching
layer and then the switching layer
itself is a programmable software switch
based on open V switch and and that's
the core data plane for data processing
so as an example of how this works again
we've got we talked about internal load
balancers so this slide here is about
how
we use how we separate first of all the
control plane and the data plane
so the VMC and the EFI's are where the
are where the control plane happens and
those those program the the those pardon
me program the data plane so in this
case what we've got is control messages
being exchanged between the client vm
and the and the CF es and also with the
with the vm controllers and the cluster
fabric manager
we've got stats for health reporting and
we've also got health checks happening
for for on the other end for for load
balancing high availability and then
finally you've got VM to VM traffic
something to point out here again is
typical load balancers have middle boxes
but our approach for for the il be as I
as I described before is that we built
the load balancers as distributed
services so what's happening is these
health checks are actually checking
services on backends across multiple
across multiple backends and the client
VM in this case is where the load
balancer itself is running and we're
programming paths to those backends
directly into each of the hosts
right both forward and reverse so then
we can also extend those functions and I
think the interesting thing about this
is we can extend those functions without
changing topologies because again we
don't have middle boxes so all we have
to do is control the control our pardon
me configure the control planes so that
we can update the data plane to add that
new function into a path so if we add an
on-prem situation and a VPN it's very
simple for us to then program the flow
to the VPN termination point that
programs the backends that allow that
allowed the load balancer to connect to
those back-end VPNs again we didn't
change any topology this was simply a
software a software driven operation
okay so let's talk about network
programming models so it's interesting
when you're doing when you're doing a
software
define Network you have to you have to
program all of these flows we you're not
using distributed routing technologies
for to enable every every device to talk
to any other device you're not using ARP
for example to say okay who has this IP
address we actually have to install
flows for every single for every single
conversation that could possibly happen
so when we started we started with by
configuring full mesh communications and
that happened that works really well for
small networks but it starts to get
really ugly for big networks and that's
what this is showing this is actually a
quadratic scaling problem and in order
to in order to solve this we had to do
something different so what we did is we
came up with a concept called
hoverboards basically hoverboards are a
software gateway we use this to program
simple paths from every VM through
through that software gateway to any
other VM so rather than having a full
mesh you you traverse the hoverboard and
we and we still pre-program small
networks so small networks still have a
full mesh large networks have have
hoverboards and all those packets go
through the hoverboards and then if the
flows get too heavy in other words if
the hoverboards reach any scaling
constraints we just offload those we
actually program a direct flowed into
the client and/or the two hosts that
need to talk to each other so by doing
that this software gateway allowed us to
to achieve some really staggering
scaling improvements and what we found
out and one of the design questions that
we had to ask ourselves when we when we
built those hoverboards is actually is
this going to hurt by putting these
middle boxes into in between all of all
of this so we get a scaling benefit from
the confirm the configuration and
control plane but are we going to suffer
on the data plane and it turns out that
the vast majority of hosts never talk to
each other and then the vast majority of
hosts that actually do talk to each
other are very very quiet we're talking
less than a hundred millisecond kilobits
per second and so basically we have a
- hold that says hey anything that's got
that's got a larger flow than this will
just offload that to the host so
oftentimes we get questions so how can I
ensure that my hosts will directly talk
to each other if I have a latency
sensitive application that's really
simple send a lot of traffic so there we
go so again we were able to reduce the
programming time by buying him by
implementing the hoverboards we were
able to improve programming times by a
factor of 37 X so that was a that was a
really really important achievement for
to scale this network to the millions of
users that we that we now have we also
found that we could use hoverboards to
scale not just between vm's but also
between zones and so we just took it to
the next level and said okay well if
we've got if we've got hoverboards
inside the region between VMs we also
know that ok the communications between
two hosts on on different zones is also
like will they be quiet and it turns out
that that's also the case so what we did
is we also in inserted hoverboards
between zones and so again two hosts one
in each one in each different zone in
the same region the low bandwidth routes
traverse the hoverboards we do local
stats this is also an interesting detail
of the hoverboards you might think that
the hoverboard itself is actually
measuring the size of the the size of
the bandwidth between the two hosts but
it's actually stats that are that are
driven from the host itself and that's
to prevent the hoverboard from right at
the moment when it actually is suffering
or Annie needs more resources we're not
trying to make it more busy we can
actually just offload that to the host
itself and the host itself can create
its own flows and this is another
benefit of distributing our network
functions across multiple across the
host themselves so when we see those
stats and and the the bandwidth is high
we just go straight host-to-host so
again this works just like inside of a
zone it's just one more hierarchy of our
board so I'm gonna switch gears here now
and talk about the the way that we do
networking at the host level and one of
the things that people may find odd or
at least unique about us is that that we
do all of our networking on the host
level in user space and and so kind of
first of all why do we why do we do this
in software and we'll get to the the
reasons why we do this in user space but
the primary reason is we're able to get
native hardware performance in software
we've our fast path which is basically
just doing packet forwarding is able to
push three million packets per second
with one dedicated CPU per host and that
translates to greater than 30 gigabits
per second on ideal situations then we
also use coprocessors for cpu intensive
functions like denial of service
protection IP rewrites etc we'll talk
more about that in a second and then we
also have an on host control plane and
with an on host control plane we're able
to do things like by migrations and
hitless upgrades because we can just
swap out like we can swap out the the
data plane right underneath that control
plane without losing any without losing
any state so again why building user
space well there are a lot of advantages
first of all there's security advantages
it runs without route so pretty much the
entire data plane has no privileges and
secondly we can do things like
continuous fuzzing because the code
footprint is so small we can also we can
also do things like address space
randomization it also improves
robustness so unlike a kernel bug which
could take a whole take down a whole
machine a user process can go down and
come right back
and likewise user space processes allow
for nearly weekly upgrades we are
hitless upgrade process live migrations
again also allow for VMs to be migrated
between physical hosts without
disruption enabling transparent OS
maintenance so it also provides a
flexible architecture so our data plane
is fully programmable the control plane
basically programs open flow rules and
the data plane itself it's pretty simple
the example on this slide we have three
tables in cap D cap and maybe some
special functions this all programs the
data plane which is a key action based
data plane and we also do we've also
enhanced the overall V switch layer to
include things like stateful load
balancing which aren't available in your
standard in your standard implementation
of V switch D it also does different
features for us we've created custom
features for ourselves like stats and
billing and we also have the ability to
do policy enforcement these network
functions are also applied directly in
the data plan via coprocessors so again
coprocessors outside of the fast path
which again the fast path is primarily
just doing forwarding these these
functions outside the fast path include
things like traffic shaping denial of
service protection abuse protection IP
address rewrites so for example when
you're when you're trying to send
packets to the internet you have to do a
rewrite from that private IP address to
a public IP address all that happens in
the coprocessor so a little bit of
history about about our CPU efficiency
gains as we've as we've improved
Andromeda first of all when we built
this stuff it became very very evident
that we needed to minimize the host and
gas network CPU cycles per byte and the
way that we did that was over time
moving off of moving off of the guest
completely or pardon me off of the host
completely and by passing by passing as
much of the guest as possible so in the
Andromeda 1.1 point
implementation there was a kernel open V
switch and the open V switch control
plane on top and then a hypervisor the
kernel data path only had support for
egress egress data offload but it didn't
have support for ingress data offload as
a consequence you can see that that
resulted in a lot of host cycle host CPU
cycles and drama 21.5 optimized the host
data path
it added ingress for offload support or
pardon me it added ingress offload
support but maintain the kernel data but
still maintain the kernel data path this
at this optimization along with the
introduction of receive offload support
improved both the guests and the host
CPU performance but and it also allowed
for live migrations which was a pretty
big deal we couldn't do that before we
had ingress support but the real big
evolution came with Andromeda 2.0 there
the entire data plane was moved in the
user space but we still required one
thread of handoff so there were there
was still a software virtual NIC that we
had that we had to talk to you and so
there was a there was a context switch
but as you can see there was still a
significant reduction in the cycles per
by it with 2.1 we moved that one thread
handoff and with 2.2 we've added support
for memory copy off loads and that's led
to decrease in more than more than 50
cycles per byte since we started with
Andromeda 1.0 so some throughput numbers
on a single core per host data data
plane again the fast path uses one
dedicated CPU on each host the on one
single core / house for our data pane on
skylight testbed hosts both host both
host connected to the top to the same
top of racks which we're able to get 38
gigabits per second throughput again
this is ideal situation scenarios we
don't support 38 gigabits per second in
VMs all right you're laughing I have
something for you so anyway so we also
noticed some VM to VM round-trip time
latency the so again with the single
core per host and in the same top of
top-of-rack switch on sky like it
infrastructure we had normal tcp
round-trip time in the order of 25
milliseconds with our tcp busy polling
so we're not doing interrupt driven
networking anymore we were able to lower
that down to 15 milliseconds and with DB
DK were able to lower that below 10
milliseconds alright so a quick summary
so what we talked about today global
network why is a global network
important it's easier to deploy you've
got fewer things to do it's more
reliable the infrastructure that we
built is heavily redundant it's more
flexible you have the ability to operate
functions both globally and and locally
we talked about Andromeda the key
principles between Andromeda are
isolation performance and agility
so isolation again we've got performance
and and functional isolation we have to
keep keep all of these Network
namespaces distinct and agility we need
to be able to improve as we as we build
right and so this this agility that
we've built into this allows us to do
weekly upgrades and then finally some
network functions and by the way this is
by no means complete oh I gave away that
goes so anyway these network functions
are are by no means the comprehensive
list hopefully you've been spending some
time with this and and you know that
there are many global network functions
there are many regional Network
functions we only talked about a few and
then I have one more thing for those
that were snickering a little bit we are
announcing today that we support 32
gigabit per second networking host a
host the way that we talk about the way
that we talk about networking in our
cloud is a general rule of thumb is that
you get about 2 gigabits per second per
V CPU so up until today that scaled up
to 16 Giga bits per second so you on an
8 CPU but all right VP but an 8 V CPU
box you could get 16 gigabits per second
now this requires the skylake platform
however with a with a 16 CPU skylight
platform you can get up to 32 32
gigabits per second
it requires zero configuration there's
no SR Iove required no no different
drivers you can use a standard Verdi a
driver and this will just work with that
I'd like to invite you to go to the rest
of our networking conferences or our
networking breakouts for the rest of the
week there's a there's an interesting
hybrid one tomorrow that one of my
colleagues is giving and there's also
again 9 a.m. tomorrow we have an IP IP
addressing in the cloud panel which I
think you know I'm a nerd but I think
this is a really cool topic and then if
you want a cloud poster go to GCO slash
poster and you can download one or we'll
ship it to you all right
[Music]